hey youtubers is Charlie so it just had
a chance to see the guardians of the
galaxy IMAX preview so this is gonna be
a review that whenever I get to spoilers
I'll just say it's spoiler warning but
I'm gonna do my non-spoilery review
first it was just 17 minutes the full
movie is a little over two hours so it
almost felt like nothing like it blew
right by hello to new people if you're
finding me for the first time I do
Marvel videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything I have a
whole bunch of links down in the
description if you want to travel down
the YouTube Marvel rabbit hole so most
of the footage expanded on things we've
already seen in the trailers like the
lineup it adds a lot more context for
other characters like Gamora
Karen Gillan's nebula Ronan most of the
stuff we saw took place inside that
prison and it's really designed to tell
non Marvel you know super comic-book
geeks who these characters are it's
really meant for people that haven't
read the comics you know who these
people what are their motivations I know
a lot of you ask me sometimes if you
need to read a book or a comic before
you see an episode of TV or a movie you
do not need to read anything before you
go to see guardians the movie does all
the work it takes care of all the
explaining in really funny quick ways it
doesn't waste any time that could be
used to move the story forward which is
amazing I also really enjoyed that each
of the characters and the Guardians like
The Guardian characters narrate the
other characters backstories based on
what we saw I feel like the movie will
work so well that it doesn't need to
explain anything even if you don't know
anything about the comics you're gonna
love this movie even way back during
Comic Con last year when we were all
sitting in the audience and we saw that
really short teaser of the lineup with
hooked on a feeling said to it I feel
like we understood that this is gonna be
the kind of movie that's gonna change
what you think superhero movies are
allowed to do it makes me very very
hopeful for what even weirder movies
like Doctor Strange are going to look
like whenever they get here bottom line
is you have to go see this movie when it
comes out on August 1st if you have the
opportunity to see it in IMAX definitely
do but you do not need to see it in 3d I
feel like it hurts more movies than it
helps but it's gonna be awesome no
matter what format you see it in so
let's talk about spoilers now careful in
case you don't want to know anything
because I'm just gonna go beat for beat
what we actually saw in the footage so
everybody ready here we go so we open on
john c reilly dialog when they're
getting processed but it opens up and
shows us bits from different characters
rune annealing it Thanos's rocket thrown
from avengers the rocket throne shows up
in almost every comic that Thanos is in
it's one of the most iconic set pieces
is a big part of his character we start
getting everyone's backstories Gamora
who was basically adopted by Thanos and
turned into a killing machine she lets
us know that what she came from is so
much worse than the threat of Ronan's
accuser chord that that's just part of
the reason why she's so willing to go
apeshit like the threats that they face
aren't half as bad as Thanos Thanos is
way worse but he actually was not in the
footage that was unfortunate we also
kind of learned what the relationship
between her character and Karen Gillan's
and nebula is you know they're basically
both like daughters of Thanos and nebula
is just jealous that Gamora gets the
favorable treatment as the adopted
daughter just imagine a prequel with
those three characters like a Disney
movie it'd be like some awful terrible
twisted Disney Princess tale I would
totally go see that then we learned a
little bit about Peter quill especially
how attached he is to his artifacts from
Earth he's the son of a human woman and
the Sparta Emperor he's basically a
prince who just hates his father he
spent most of his adult life in space
traveling as part of yondu's crew of
Thieves Michael Rooker yondu is
essentially a pirate in this movie so
you can understand why they cast Michael
Rooker there's a little bit of shipping
between Gamora and Peter quill but if
you've read the comics that you know she
doesn't really have relationships like
normal people do so they're not like a
couple or anything rocket racoon
explains tracks saying he's from this
super literate race is pretty hilarious
it just comes off as funny because you
know you look at him and he's freaking
huge just picture him wearing a pair of
reading glasses then we get a good shot
of raccoon getting hosed down and you
see all the cybernetic implants in his
body it's really horrific he's basically
a normal raccoon that was experimented
on that's how he gained bipedal motion
the ability to speak in his heightened
intelligence group mostly comes off as
the gentle giant that he's seen like in
the trailers you know he's like a big
puppy dog but then they all get walked
into gen-pop
and people start going crazy someone
tries to beat the crap out of Peter
quill until rocket and Groot go crazy on
him and declare he's under their
protection that's actually the scene
from the trailer with them spinning
around screaming it's pretty funny Groot
disarms one of them by growing roots up
his nose so then it moves into
prison-break mode which is like a huge
action set piece
they basically plan something then
totally messes it up not wanting to hurt
anyone and it's just non-stop action
until they get caught it's basically
like that scene from Winter Soldier
wherever Captain America jumped on the
ship in the beginning and took down
everyone on the boat without stopping to
take a breath it's like a non-stop
continuous action scene very intense
very cool then it moves on to like a
rocket computer hacking scene and
reminded me of that scene in The
Avengers whenever Bruce Banner and Tony
Stark
are geeking out in the staff room I feel
like the three of them would have a good
time together making science so then we
get to see a little bit more of the bad
guys it was only Ronan kneeling at
Thanos's rocket throne no Thanos but
still very cool and we got to see a
full-on shot of Michael Rooker this is
what he looks like
Ronan's dark aster this huge huge ship
is supposed to be like a couple miles
long is awesome we also got to see a
longer version of the trailer scene
where rocket is flying his warbird
around nowhere destroying Ronan's
necrocraft ships it's basically like one
of the big battle scenes that was pretty
much it it actually didn't seem like a
whole lot of footage it was just so
awesome it just went by so fast
Marvel is kind of like a crack dealer
standing on the corner just giving away
free footage you definitely get the
sense though that Marvel's building up
to some sort of Santos centric movie but
it's still a long ways off I just can't
wait to hear Josh Brolin's Thanos voice
they basically did most of the movie
before they cast him they're basically
just bringing him at the end to do the
dialogue even though we haven't even
seen the movie yet they've already been
a lot of rumors about what's gonna be
happening in the sequel and possible
crossovers with other Marvel teams but I
feel like this movie just by itself is
gonna be a huge watershed moment for
weirdness this really is like the test
for Phase three next year can Marvel
spend a hundred and fifty million
dollars on weirdness of this level like
I'm a huge fan of the comic so of course
I would say yes but I feel like this
movie is so non geek friendly that it's
totally something you could take your
mom to and she would also enjoy unless
your mom is also a comic book geek and
then right on the actual movie isn't
gonna be out till August 1st so
guardians will not be going to comic-con
they're gonna be promoting their other
upcoming movies like Avengers 2 Ant Man
and probably confirming which other
films would be part of phase 3 I think
those other two will be Doctor Strange
and Black Widow I'm dead
we planning on dr. strange but the other
option instead of BlackWidow would be
the second guardians movie The Guardian
sequel Marvel hasn't officially said
anything about a guardian sequel but
they typically release sequels you know
every two to three years so I'm really
hoping we don't have to wait all the way
to phase four before we see guardians
too but if you had a chance to see that
IMAX footage let me know in the comments
what was your favorite moment and if you
didn't get to see it what are you
looking forward to most in the movie I
know we all just want to see more
Infinity Gauntlet we just want to see
all the gems come together so my next
bonus video is gonna post next week be
sure to subscribe to get it
tons of Marvel links down in the
description so check that also you can
click here to get my room in the accuser
video and you can click here to learn
about Brandon Roth becoming the new Adam
character on arrow season 3 that's
actually pretty exciting so thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives